I'm Devin Stone a practicing lawyer and
adjunct law professor and host of the
legal eagle law Channel and I'm here to
answer your questions from Twitter this
is law support
[Music]
from at granule where is the line
between hate speech and Free Speech
actually there is no line a lot of
countries take different philosophies
when it comes to hate speech but in the
United States hate speech has the same
kind of First Amendment protections as
most speech now there are some
quasi-exceptions to that when it comes
to certain crimes you can get an
enhancement if it was done for a
racially or hate related reason but for
the most part just when we're talking
about Free Speech hate speech is free
speech and you can love it or hate it
reasonable Minds will differ on that one
from airbag moments serious question for
lawyers if I threaten my judge with
death in the courtroom isn't he she now
prejudiced against me and must be
replaced so this is a great example of
the difference between prejudice and
undue Prejudice courts are designed to
prevent things that cause undue
Prejudice in the courtroom we don't want
an outside influence unfairly
prejudicing the judge the jury or anyone
else but what happens inside the court
room is pretty much fair game that might
be prejudicial but that's not unfair or
undue Prejudice so don't go around
threatening the judge with death
whatever happens in court can and will
be used against you from Blue Road Earth
why was OJ found not guilty in criminal
court but liable in civil court this
question was phrased very well because
they show the difference between
liability and criminal liability or
guilt in this context now the standard
in a criminal case is beyond a
reasonable doubt so if someone is found
not guilty it doesn't mean that they
didn't commit a crime it just means that
the prosecution didn't meet their burden
now in the Civil context you're trying
to make the victims whole for the
damages that you have caused them and
that's exactly what the Estates of
Nicole Brown Simpson and Ron Goldman did
with O.J Simpson even though the state
was not successful in criminally
Prosecuting O.J Simpson they were
successful in filing a civil suit where
the standard is only a preponderance of
the evidence basically more likely than
not from at marzo bound when is a
Grandeur used over a regular jury if
it's just ordinary people either way so
the jury that actually decides whether
someone is guilty or not is called a
petty jury
p-e-t-i-t it's Latin don't ask a grand
jury on the other hand is actually a
much lower bar a grand jury is used by
prosecutors to decide whether to indict
someone and the reason that people often
say a grand jury could indict a ham
sandwich is because it's completely
one-sided it's really just a basic check
to decide whether the case can go
forward it doesn't actually decide
whether someone's guilty or not B Brooks
4791s why not testify if you're innocent
why plead the fifth if you're innocent
this applies to anyone it does actually
apply to anyone just because you are
invoking the Fifth Amendment which is
the protection against
self-incrimination and being forced to
testify against yourself that doesn't
mean that you committed any crimes maybe
you don't want to testify because that
might open you up to unrelated crimes
you might be innocent at the thing
you're accused of but might be guilty of
a whole bunch of other things or you
might be completely innocent of
everything and just not want to testify
you might be really bad on the stand so
be glad that if you're ever accused of a
crime you aren't going to be forced to
testify against yourself you have the
option not to testify from Merck the
mods how do DraftKings and FanDuel get
around anti-gambling laws so for a long
time FanDuel and DraftKings were
completely illegal across the entire U.S
except for Fantasy related sports
betting those are generally considered
games of skill however when it comes to
General betting on a sports book that
was considered gambling and was illegal
until 2018 when the Supreme Court struck
that law down it was left up to the
states and now there have been a lot of
states that have said we are totally
fine with people gambling in our states
we would really like the tax revenue and
as a result it's now legal to use online
websites like FanDuel and DraftKings
from I should 12. how much of a
difference is there between a guilty
plea versus no contest so if you are
accused of a criminal violation you have
a couple options if you don't want to go
to trial you could just enter a plea of
guilty but sometimes you have the option
to plead no contest effectively in the
criminal context you're treated exactly
the same as if you had pled guilty if
your crime harmed someone and they then
sued you after you pled guilty well you
would be civilly liable for whatever
damages you caused almost automatically
because the standard in a criminal case
is so much higher than a civil case but
if you plead no contest they have to
prove that you are liable in the Civil
context generally speaking if the option
is available a smart defendant will
plead no contest rather than guilty from
Red Rollins one you know why there are
so many frivolous lawsuits in America so
I think that people vastly overestimate
how many frivolous lawsuits there are
it's it's a lot of selection bias going
on you're not going to hear about a
breach of contract case that involves a
vendor who got 10 000 industrial widgets
when he ordered 12 000 industrial
widgets and some of them were
non-conforming you're not going to hear
about that because it's super boring but
you are going to hear about the most
ridiculous cases that are out there the
most frivolous cases because those are
the ones that are interesting and are
going to make news from better Tech and
lo and behold umg sues for fake Drake
and the weekend song generated by AI but
whom can it sue apart from the company
that made the AI artists do often have
rights to their likeness and sometimes
even the rights to how they sound but we
are entering a Brave New World where
where the law is going to come down in
terms of what constitutes infringement
or not it's going to be an interesting
outcome because it's not at all obvious
where that's going to come down C dashel
asks can you actually avoid being sued
by simply avoiding being served papers
that would be a ridiculous loophole I
agree that would be ridiculous and
generally speaking that's not the case
what happens is if you avoid service for
long enough you get to do what's called
substitution of service where instead of
physically handing the service papers to
someone you just put it into a newspaper
and then you might not even know that
the proceedings have started and believe
me you do not want to have a lawsuit
against you and not participate what
happens is a default judgment where you
just lose and you didn't get a chance to
defend yourself don't play games accept
service and just hire a lawyer it's the
better way to do it from extra spicy
Tums why are there so many accident
lawyer Billboards in La can someone
enlighten me here because once I started
noticing them I can't stop now there was
actually a Supreme Court case in the
1970s that allowed lawyers to advertise
on billboards before that the law said
they couldn't and look if you are going
to advertise uh related to car accidents
putting up a billboard is probably the
best way to do it query whether you are
creating more accidents but that's just
what we call a virtuous cycle you're
creating your own market so that sounds
great from at quasi-asher wait how is
jury duty the TV show remotely legal
waivers lots and lots of waivers from at
you let Kai spare tips to make studying
law less boring please I would say say
this behind every single case is a story
and unless you are studying civil
procedure you can basically ignore the
procedure of a case and just focus on
the story of what happened whether
you're talking about a breach of
contract or a horrible accident there's
probably something really interesting
going on in the background and it makes
it a lot easier to remember and it makes
it more interesting to study as well
from at hbn W7 why does the law have to
be complicated and expensive question
mark question mark question mark it's
because lawyers hate you and they want
to make an example of you you in
particular
lawyers get a lot of flack our job is to
be careful and the thing is reality is
really complicated there's a lot of
stuff that can go wrong if you're
writing a contract or you're writing a
law you have to make sure that you cover
all of the different edge cases and not
only that language is really complicated
especially the English language so
there's a million different cases about
what constitutes a chicken what happens
if a boat has the same name as another
boat what happens if you write a law and
you you forget a comma all of those
things have absolutely happened judges
juries and lawyers have to try and
figure out what to do when something is
ambiguous and the world is ambiguous all
the time from Spring to Mage how do
lawyers ethically defend their client
when there is say video evidence of them
trying to run over a person twice
everyone is entitled to a good defense
and there are a million different
reasons and ways that a lawyer might
defend even a guilty person even if they
think that person is guilty maybe the
prosecutor is trying to convict someone
and get a sentence that's way way too
high you don't want someone who's
accused of petty burglary to face the
death penalty and so you know there are
a lot of different degrees that you can
use to defend someone regardless of
whether they're guilty or not and
everyone deserves a reasonable defense
shoob got him 52 will AI replace lawyers
you probably don't want an AI lawyer
anytime soon a lawyer is not just simply
a machine that knows what the law is a
lawyer is a person with theoretically
years of expertise that can help you
strategically to achieve your goals and
that's not something that AI is well
positioned to replace anytime soon what
I suspect is going to happen is that AI
is going to make a lot of the drudgery
practicing law way easier and it will
allow lawyers to focus on the really
value-add stuff and allow them to think
strategically and to better represent
their clients in the future so I welcome
our AI overlords from Dean hair photo
when does attorney client privilege end
and that the lawyer is a co-conspirator
begin well there is a law on point and
that is called the crime fraud exception
if a lawyer helps a client engage in
fraud then the attorney-client privilege
is pierced and theoretically if the
lawyer really is engaging in criminality
then they can become a co-conspirator
from butterfly babes five why is perjury
not enforced so many are saying nothing
will happen to hashtag Amber Heard for
lying under oath then what's the point
of taking the oath so first of all well
perjury is actually enforced perjury
being lying under oath that being said
it's really hard to convict someone of
perjury just because you lost
mean that you engaged in lying and in
fact even in the Amber Heard Johnny Depp
context where there was a counter suit
and Johnny Depp won that doesn't
necessarily mean that anyone on the
other side of that was necessarily lying
and generally speaking you know
prosecutors have better things to
prosecute than a marginal case of
potential perjury from Molly Haynes how
do lawyers just know the law like I had
to learn the nitty-gritty of one law and
it drove me nuts you're telling me law
students just learn every law and then
some international law lawyers rarely
know every law the body of American law
that's out there is just it's too huge
and it's not possible for any one person
to know what tends to happen is you know
the law that you use in practice all the
time say a prayer for all the lawyers
out there because if you come to us with
a novel question we're probably not
going to know the law off the top of our
head and we're gonna have to research it
and frankly you want it that way from
Peter Unwin when a driverless car is
involved in an accident who should be
responsible when a driverless car gets
into an accident and there are two
potential Avenues of liability one is
negligence and the other is product
liability when it comes to product
liability basically if you put a product
into the stream of Commerce you're
what's called strictly liable for any
damages that that product causes a
manufacturer could also be liable based
on a negligence theory that there was
some industry Norm they should have
followed and they didn't but there are a
million other people that might also be
liable under a negligence Theory maybe
there was another driver who was
responsible it's going to be a
case-by-case basis but those are going
to be the the leading theories under
which someone's going to be liable from
Nazi gerlock one how does the Supreme
Court choose to hear a case that is a
fascinating process the short answer
there is that of the nine justices four
of them have to agree to take up a case
you cannot appeal to the Supreme Court
as a matter of right the Supreme Court
has to issue what's called a writ of
certiori in other words they only decide
what cases they hear now on what basis
do the Supreme Court Justices decide
often if there's a conflict between the
states if there's a matter of supreme
National importance like we saw in Bush
versus Gore or Roe versus Wade sometimes
they'll take on a case just because they
want to interpret a law or statute the
way that they want to interpret it from
Leslie W string of numbers can there
even be a real crime in the metaverse if
it does not translate into a real crime
in the physical Universe well there's
all kinds of crimes in the real world
that do not involve a physical act
there's the civil action of defamation
and that can happen in the real world or
in the metaverse if you meet the
elements of a crime in the metaverse I
would suspect that that crime is going
to be prosecuted in the same way that it
would be prosecuted in real life too
from friend of Gandalf why is there a
statute of limitations for crimes the
reason the statute of limitations exists
is because after a whole lot of time has
passed often it can be really hard to
find evidence it might be impossible to
find witnesses so it's a balancing act
we want to punish the guilty but we
don't want to punish the innocent so we
have a statute of limitations to make
sure that it's fair here for a defendant
to be able to defend themselves in a
case where a lot of time has passed and
otherwise they wouldn't be able to
defend themselves from stove allergy
when lawyers say something in court and
object to it and the judge tells the
jury to disregard that do they think
it's deleted from their brains no
definitely not lawyers are fully
cognizant of the fact that things that
happen in court even when you get a
limiting instruction from the judge it's
impossible for anyone to literally
forget what has happened that being said
a judge knows when you're screwing
around and if the judge thinks that you
are intentionally violating the decorum
of the Court the judge will use
something called contempt and sometimes
lawyers go to jail over things that they
did in a courtroom Chloe Walker asks
it's like appeal appeal and appeal until
you get the answer you like is that
Justice how many appeals do you get so
generally speaking you only get one
appeal now theoretically there are
different courts of appeal so you might
theoretically get one more shot at the
Apple but courts of appeal that are
above the intermediate court of appeal
are like the Supreme Court and they only
take the cases that they want so it's
very rare to go past one appeal all
right that's all of our questions I hope
you learned something today and until
next time I'll see you in court